[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
عاده يكون هناك وسيله للتواصل بين الاخرين
نستطيع من خلالها ان نتعرف على الاخر ابرز
وسيله للتواصل هي اللغه عندما نسمع اكثر
من شخص او شخصين او شخص واحد يتكلم مباشره
نستطيع من خلال هذه اللغه انحدد جنسيته ان
نحدد ممكن ديانته من خلال بعض الالفاظ
التي يستخدمها نستطيع ان نحدد مستواها
ثقافي اذا اللغه هي مفتاح للشخصيات او
التعرف على الشخصيات احيانا لا نرى
الاشخاص لكن نسمع اصواتهم نستطيع من
خلالها ايضا التعرف على المعلومات الاوليه
او البيانات الاوليه للاشخاص ليست اللغه
المكتوبه اليست اللغه المنطوقه فقط حتى
اللغه المكتوبه تعطي معرفه بالاخر لوصلت
الى رساله من مجهول عبر الجوال رساله نصيه
باي وسيله كانت مناسب التواصل الاجتماعي
بعض الالفاظ او بعض الكلمات او بعض
التراكيب تعطيك دلاله على اصحابها اليس
كذلك اذا اللغه هي الهويه هي التي تترجم
عن الاخر هي التي تعرف به عندما اتحدث
يقع كثير من الناس في الخلط عندما يقول
اللغويه او اللغويه اليس كذلك ما هو الفرق
بين اللغويه هو اللغويه اللغويه من اللغو
وليس من اللغه الصواب ان نقول اللغويه
الان نحن في
هذا المؤتمر وهذه التداعيه الثقافيه
العظيمه جدا لاحظنا كثيرا من يقول الهويه
الهويه الهويه الهويه الوطنيه الهويه
الثقافيه الهويه الدينيه والصواب هي
الهويه الهويه من هو اذا هويتي هو انا
وظيفتي اليها هي النسب والمربوطه
هناك تداخل بين الهويه وبين اللغه هي
علاقه تكامليه علاقتكاتفيه لا يوجد فرق
بين الهويه اللغويه
الهويه هي اشمل من اللغه اللغه هي جزء من
الهويه تحدث فيها
الهويه هي تاريخنا ثقافتنا جنسيتنا ديننا
لباسنا هذه كلها تدخل ضمن الهويه اذا
اللغه هي جزء من الهويه او المظله الكبيره
التي ننتمي اليها وهي الهويه الوطنيه او
الهويه الثقافيه والاجتماعيه الى غيرها من
النوع الهويات
هناك نوع من الهويه الخاصه تميز كل شخص
بنفسه لك اسلوبك الخاص في الحديث لك
اسلوبك الخاص بالتعامل لكاسلوبك الخاص في
اللباس لك اسلبك هذه هويتك الخاصه شخصيتك
انت وهناك هويه لغويه خاصه ايضا هناك
مفردات ربما تكون خاصه بفرد خاصه بمنطقه
خاصه بقبيله ونحن نعيش في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في خليط عظيم جدا من اللغات
واللهجات تختلف احيانا منطقه نجد لوحدها
انك تختلف عن القصيم عن اليس كذلك عن سكان
الخرج اذا هي امتزاج عظيم جدا هذه الهويات
الخاصه اللغويه الخاصه
تنضم اليها او تذوب تماما عندما نتحدث عن
الهويه السعوديه الهويه السعوديه هو وطننا
كلنا جميعا هناك لغه نتحدث بها جميعا
نتواصل بها جميعا الان في هذا المجلس انا
اثق انه معظم جنسيات او معظم عفوا المناطق
المملكه موجودين هنا صح وينتمون الاعراب
كثيره جدا منهم من خارج الحدود الوطن وما
هذا كلنا نتحدث بلغه ونتواصل بها سواء
داخل الوطن او خارج الوطن ممن ينتمون
الينا لغويا
كما كتبوها لماذا لان اللغه التي
استخدموها هي نفسها اللغه التي نتحدث عنها
ونفهمها نحن عندما نتحدث عن الهويه لغويه
ونريد ان نتحدث او نستعيد هذه اللغه لا
نريد ان نتحدث تلك اللغه الموجوده في
امهات الكتب
المهات الكتب هي في امهات الكتب اللغه لا
تعيش الا بالتواصل والاستخدام
والتعاطي معها في حياتنا باستمرار حتى مع
الاخر احنا لابد ان نبرز هويتنا
هناك من يقول ان اللغه العربيه قاصره لا
نستطيع ان نعبر عن او لا تفي بمتطلباتنا
او حديثنا او الى اخره
ويتهمها بالقصور يضرب لذلك مثال او يحتاج
بانها اخذت من جميع لغات الدول التي
دخلتها المسلمون فتح العرب فيها كلمات
فارسيه في كلمات تركيه في كلمات يونانيه
في كلمات هنديه الى اخره
هذا ليس عيبا وقدحا في اللغه العربيه
اطلاقا هذا دليل على كمالها على مرونتها
انها تستطيع ان تستوعب كل هذه اللغات
وتروضها بما يعرف بالتعريب التعريب ان
الكلمه تؤخذ من اللغات الاخرى ثم بعد ذلك
تدخل في هذه اللغه وتخضع لقواعدها كلمه
بشت
كلكم تعرفون البشت صح معناها الظهر في لغه
خراسان دخلت الى اللغه العربيه عربت فاصبح
لها جمع واصبح لها مثنى واصبحت تعرب اذا
خضعت لقواعد اللغه العربيه احيانا ليس لان
اللغه العربيه عاجزه عن
المصطلحات جميع المصطلحات موجوده فيها
ولكن احيانا تستسهل الكلمه التي موجوده في
تلك البلاد التي فتحوها او التي خلطوها
بالتعايش مثلا مثلا لو قلنا كلمه التوت
توت ليست عربيه
الفصيح منها هو
التوت معناه فرصات بالفصيح لكن استسهل
العرب كلمه التوت الفارسيه على تلك النبته
من استخدام كلمه الفرصاد اذا ليس عجلا هي
لديها المعنى ولديها المصطلح ولكن لم
استسهال الناس لاستخدام بعض المصطلحات او
بعض الكلمات جعلهم يستخدمون هذه اللغه
بالاضافه الى ان اللغه العربيه كانت
تستعير وكانت تعير ايضا اللغات الاخرى في
القاموس الاسباني وجد اكثر من اربعه الاف
كلمه من اصول عربيه في المعجم الاسباني في
المعجم مثلا كلمه القلعه في اللغه
الاسبانيه اسمها كالا
لماذا قال لانه لا ينطقون العين
يستبدونها بالالف الفيل بالاسبانيه هو
نفسه الفيل اذا الكلمات دخلت كما هي وربما
خففت لبعض مراعاه حالاته ومخارج الحروف
لان اللغه العربيه او نتكلم العربيه يتحدث
اي لغه لان جميع مخارج حروفها سليمه لكن
من يتحدث لغات اخرى قد تصعب عليه بعض
الحروف النطقه مثل حرف العين حرف الحاء لا
تجنب بعض اللغات تستصعب هذا الحرب حرف
الثاء ايضا ثقيل على بعض اللغات
فكون اللغه العربيه تتلاقى مع غيرها او
تستعير وتعير هذا ليس عيبا فيها بالاضافه
الى ان اللغات الاخرى ايضا اخذت من اللغه
العربيه مثلا
لو قلنا في كلمه كفر الكاف والفاء والراء
هذا جذر في اللغه العربيه معناه
التغطيه او الستر فلما نجي نشوف ان هذه
اللغه كفر الله سبحانه وتعالى استخدمها في
القران الكريم عندما وصف بها المزارعين
قال يعجب الكفار نباتا لماذا الله سبحانه
وتعالى وصف الكفار بانهم وصف المزارعين
بانهم كفار
ما سبب لانهم يخفون او يغطون البذور في
باطن الارض ومن ذلك تسمى بعض المراه كذلك
الكافر يقوم بتغطيه الايمان وهو الفطره
السليمه في صدره ولا يظهره
البعض المناطق الريفيه في مصر وغيرها من
الدول العربيه تسبب المناطق اللي فيها كفر
كفر الشيخ وكفر لماذا سميت بكفر لانها
مناطق ريفيه تغرس البذور في باطن الارض
وتخفيها هذه اللغه اصليه فصيحه عربيه في
القران الكريم نجد ان استعارها من اللغات
الاخرى نجد مثلا كلمه الغطاء اللي لما
نشتري الجوال حمايه شو نسميه
كفر ترى كفر حقتنا احنا العرب هي اصلها
عربيه لكن استعارها الاخرون منا من مجل
اللغه الفرنسيه كيف اخذت هذا اللفظ منه
لما يقول كوافير ايش معنى كوافير التي
تغطي القبيح وتظهر الجميل اذا هي لغتنا
نحن اذا حتى الدول الاخرى عاله علينا على
لغتنا لسنا نحن من ياخذ لكن ان اخذنا نحن
ناخذ للتسهيل او لانها درجه على السنتهم
لكن ليس لي ضعف او عجز في اللغه العربيه
عندما نهجرها اذا نحن نحكم عليها بالموت
اللغه مثل الكائن الحي تماما لها حالات
ولاده لا حاله نضج لا حاله ازدهار لا حاله
وفاه فاللغات التي لم نستخدمها ستموت نجد
ان كثير من البعض
المؤلفين مثلا يقولون ان كلمه
الاستبراق وكلمه بعض الكلمات الموجوده في
القران الكريم يجد انها او يقولون ان
اصلها هنديه
ثم بعد ذلك نحتاج الى المسلمين يقولون لا
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى قال وانزلناهم
بلسان عربي مبين كيف نوفق بين هذا وهذا
يقول ابن تيميه من قال بالتعريف القران
فقد ظلم نفسه اللغه كائن حي كلمه السندس
والاستبرق هذه كلمات كانت دارجه في اللغه
العربيه لكن معركه التجاره اخذها الهنود
وسافروا بها انتشرت عندهم ماتت عند العرب
عندما عادت التجاره مره اخرى عاد الهنود
وهم يستخدمونها فظن من ارخ في تلك الفتره
انهم انها كلمات اخذت من اللغه الهنديه
وادخلت في القران هل القران يعجز الله
سبحانه وتعالى يختار القران لكتابه لغه
تعجز عن ايجاد او تعبير عن مصطلح اذا
اللغه العربيه هي من هي هي الاصل في هذه
المفردات وليست معربه او لكنها عادت الى
العرب مع حركات التجاره فهي عمليه مد وجزر
الحاصل الان ان الكثير من
الحملات في العصر الحديث خاصه مع
الاستعمار بدات حملات تضعف اللغه لان
اللغه هي الرباط بين القوم وبين الشعوب
بين الدول بين الحضارات فهي الرابط
الاساسي الذي يربطهم عندما يتحدث شخص من
المغرب لا استطيع ان نفهم لغته او من
السودان او من اكثر من قطر عربي لا استطيع
ان افهم لغه لكن عندما نتحدث الفصحى هي
اللغه التي نتواصل بها جميعا ونتعرف على
بعضنا البعض من خلالها
فكانت هناك حملات شرسه ضد اللغه العربيه
والمناداه بالعاميه حتى يكون هناك صعوبه
في التواصل
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الان التقنيات
الحديثه تواصل الشباب مع غيره من الجنسيات
في الالعاب والتواصل الى اخره كل هذا ادى
الى ضعف اللغه فاصبحت او يصبح الشباب
يتحدثون بلغات ليس لها اصل في لغتنا
العربيه
لكن
كذلك المحل التجاريه الان
لما في فتح المشاريع يعمد الى استخدام
اسماء اجنبيه لجذب الانتباه وكان اللغه
كانت قاصره عن
الوفاء بمثل هذه الاسماء التجاريه المشكله
ليست في الشباب هي مشكله ومشكله عظيمه جدا
لكن المشكله الامر ان تاتي هذه
الاستخدامات من نساء كبيرات في السن
يعني بقول لكم بعض المواقف اللي مريت فيها
كانت احدى الامهات احدى الجدات عفوا
تتحدث مع
مع
حفيدتها تقول لها يعني معليش انا بستخدم
هذه اللفظه بس عشان اوصل فكره تقول وين
مما تشكو نعلين اعزكم الله ونذكره في
القران الكريم فاخلان عليك انك بالوادي
المقدس مما تشكو
المراه الاخرى تطلب من بناته خليهم يرسلون
اللوكيشن طيب
يعني كانت الماساه في الشباب عظيمه فهي في
هؤلاء اعظم من يعني حتى هم وصلتهم لهذه
العجمه المشكله يعني اللغه لابد ان نحييها
يعني حتى كبار السن وصل لهم هذا التلوث
السمعي
واللفظي فبدوا يتحدثون بهذه اللغه اللغه
يعني لاحظي ان كل ما كانت الهيمنه قويه
لدوله كلما كانت لغتها قويه ليش لان بعض
المناطق او بعض الدول في العالم
المحدوده
محدوده الحدود حدودها ضيقه جدا مثل لغه
الالمانيه مثل الفرنسيه مثل كوريا حدودها
ضيقه واستخدميها فقط هذه الدوله مثلا
اللغه العربيه كم شعب يتحدث بها اللغه
الانجليزيه كم شعب يتحدث بها سواد اعظم
يتحدثون بها لكن هذه الدول المانيا وفرنسا
وكوريا ما هذا نجد ان لغتهم تنتشر في
العالم ويقبل على تعلمها اذا هذا على ماذا
دليل على قوتها وعلى هيمنتها فلذلك فرضت
سيادتها وسياده لغتها على المجتمعات الاقل
فبداوا يتحدثون بلغتهم اول من اشار الى
هذه الظاهره هي هو ابن خلدون وهو من اول
علماء اللغه الاجتماعيين الذين تحدثوا عن
محاكاه او تقليد او تبعيه لهذه اللغه
للامم المغلوبه للاسف جميع يتحدث بهذه
اللغات حتى هذه الشباب الان لو سالنا عن
ابرز او كلمه بسيطه جدا كررها باستمرار
نقول كعبه
الكعبه معروف لو سالت لماذا سميت الكعبه
بهذا الاسم
يلا سؤال اجابه سريعه
شكلها مكعب
غلط
سميت الكعبه بهذا الاسم لانها الجذر في
اللغه العربيه كاف عين باء كعب يعني
النتوء او البروز سميت الكعبه بهذه اول
بناء
ظهر على وجه الارض فلذلك سميت الكعبه بهذا
الاسم لو اردنا ان نقيس عليه الله سبحانه
وتعالى ثم الفتاه التي بدات تبرز عليها
علامات الانوثه وقال
وكواعب اترابا لماذا قال عنها كعب لان
علامات الانوثه بدات تظهر عليها كل شيء في
بروز يسماه كعب هذا هو الجذر العظم الناتئ
في اسفل القدمين ماذا نسميه
كعب لماذا
ناتئه فلذلك هذا هو اصل كلمه كعب في بعض
المناطق عندما يتورم الخد وينتفخ ويسمونه
عنده ايش وبكعب صح اعزكم الله الحذاء
العالي
كل نتوء يسمى شكله مكعب اذا هو من اصل
الكلمه او من اصل جذر كلمه كاف عين باء
اللي هو اصل الكلمه هو النتوء او البروز
لو كان لدينا هذا الوعي في لغتنا حبيناها
عروضتنا جميله جدا لكنها جرناها ما احنا
قادرين نستمتع فيها ولا احنا قادرين
نتذوقها يعني انا اتكلم عنها يمكن انا
عاشقه اللغه العربيه فنتمنى هذا العشق
ينتقل ولو بشيء بسيط وباذن الله تعالى نجد
ان شاء الله انه الجهود التي تبذلها
الدوله الان عندنا مراكز الملك سلمان
لمجمع الملك سلمان للغه العربيه
وعندنا طبعا هو مجمع دولي وليس اقليميه في
المجموعه القاهره او مجموعه بغداد او
مجموعه دمشق ومجمع دولي لخدمه اللغه
العربيه فرع ممتده لجميع لغات العالم يهتم
بغير الناطقين بالعربيه نشف العلوم
العربيه دراسات له مواقع عظيمه جدا في
خدمه العربيه نحن اهل العربيه نستفيد من
هذه المواقع
بالاضافه الى انتشار المعاهد العلميه
المعاهد غير الناطقين بها باللغه العربيه
عندنا معظم جامعاتنا لديها معاهد لغير
الناطقين باللغه العربيه جهود جباره
تبذلها الدوله والان الدوله تعيش في طبعا
لها قوه اقتصاديه سياسيه لها سياده على
مستوى العالم لماذا لا نستفيد من هذه
السياده والقوه والهيمنه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الان في على كافه الاصعده وندعم
اللغه العربيه ليصبح لها او تعود كما كانت
من قبل ونفرض احترامها وتقديرها
واستخدامها على الاخرين وابنائنا ايضا
اللغه لا تعجز عن
هذه المصطلحات لو لاحظت التجربه الكوريه
التجربه الكوريه الكوريه اخر لغه ظهرت في
العالم في العصر الحديث كانت اللغه
الكوريه الى نهايه القرن التاسع عشر بدايه
القرن العشرين ظهرت اللغه الكوريه كانت في
سابق كانت مستعمره صينيه لمده اكثر من
3000 عام ثم مصعب ماره يابانيه ثم بعد ذلك
اوجدوا لهم هذه اللغه هي لغه خليط من
اليابانيه واللغه الصينيه ولكن نفس خاص
وضعوا لهم حروف هي 24 حرف في اللغه
الكوريه رغم حداثت هذه اللغه الا ان نجد
انها الان لها السياده معظم ابنائنا
يتابعون المسلسلات الكوريه يتعرفون
يتحدثون باللغه الكوريه من اين امتدته كيف
فرضت هيمنتها لانها تمارس هذه القوه كل
دوله تريد ان تفرض او سيطرتها او قوتها
اقتصاديا وسياسيا لابد ان تروج لغتها هذا
هو دورنا هذا هو دورنا في خدمه هذه اللغه
اما ان نحييها او ان تموت القرار بيدي
وبيدك وبيدك يعطيكم العافيه السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]